[Music]
if nothing else Friday the 13th does a
great job of both making you feel weak
or powerful depending on which side
you're on playing as a camp counselor on
the run from horror icon Jason Voorhees
almost every move in Friday the 13th
could be your last one sloppy mistake
say slamming a door shut
a frightful gasp or testing your
flashlight in a moment of panic is all
it takes for Jason to quickly pinpoint
your location and move in for a kill
[Music]
unsurprisingly with Jason's strength and
supernatural powers under your command a
night at the infamous Camp Crystal Lake
takes on a far more Maleficent tone maim
rent or pulverize the innocent whatever
it takes to win the games asymmetrical
multiplayer arrangement benefits from
this dichotomy particularly because
counselors are encouraged to escape with
their wit's rather than to outright
defeat Jason however the extent to which
the game develops as you unlock new
characters and abilities remains a
mystery as we've only had a day and
about a dozen matches to put it through
its paces as such our full review will
come in the near future once we've had
the chance to explore the extent of the
game's map's characters in the multiple
ways you can fight back against the
formidable slasher Jason
some things however are immediately
clear it doesn't take long for the
hunter versus hunted dynamic to take
hold but there are also plenty of
telltale signs right up front that
Friday the 13th could benefit from
ongoing development and future updates
facial animations are often laughable
abrupt and cartoony in a way that feels
at odds with the ever-present sense of
dread you feel with Jason nipping at
your heels it's not clear whether this
was done unintentionally or for comedic
relief the most egregious example of
this is in the opening cutscene which
happens to be the same from map to map
save for backdrop adjustments Chad the
games version of the blonde moneybags
archetype from the movies has a face
that contorts like a surprise character
from a low-budget 90s CG cartoon stiff
and otherworldly there are also plenty
of mistimed and misdirected animations
that occur when sprinting around camp
and performing tasks such as opening and
closing windows characters may face the
wrong way or get caught in a stuttering
loop all these blemishes are easily
forgiven in the moment as nothing ends
up broken mid-match for long but
problems exist elsewhere that can make
even getting into a match something of a
chore currently you may find that you're
booted from a pre-match lobby on a
regular basis due to connection issues
or you may wind up in a match with
nothing on your screen save for the
mini-map in the lower right corner call
them launch woes or something else but
these events aren't uncommon enough to
simply brush off but perhaps the biggest
annoyance of all comes down to the
game's progression system which rewards
you with experience points for
completing small feats in isolation it's
a good way to look forward to new
characters with new stats in the ability
to roll for random perks as you continue
to play the game the catch is that you
need to wait for a match to end to
collect your experience which can take
upwards of 15 minutes if you're caught
by Jason early on now to be fair there
is a small chance you can be resurrected
as a special character who's armed with
a shotgun and higher stats but waiting
for minutes on end while you jump from
one player's camera to the next to pass
the time all but saps your interest in
this rare event and the match at large
we will unfortunately have to put up
with this as we continue to test Friday
the 13th servers but the hope is that
the more we play the better survivors we
become and the less downtime we'll have
to endure while it is fair to say that
the game currently bears a number of
issues it's still a very tense
experience that manages to capture the
fear that made the movies genre classics
[Music]
it would be a stretch to call Friday the
13th the game a classic in the making
but it definitely has something going
for it beyond its hockey mask wearing
murder man how that fits into the
overall picture remains to be seen so
check back in the coming days for our
full review don't stop Jason they
deserve to die make them suffer like
lead